nous sommes, nous sommes entrés dans le quartier, la salle de bain
Est plus élevé
[Musique]
la saveur est déjà lorsque vous vous brossez les dents
les dents sont horribles l'assistant l'eau
le salé est dégoûtant et c'est là qu'on réalise
comment le boire on cuisine avec de l'eau
robinet mais café
eau de thé à chauffer pour le maté
à base d'eau minérale
[Musique]
comme moi, comment puis-je acheter des fûts de
20 litres qui sont généralement en 300
pesos et j'en ai acheté deux par semaine
[Musique]
nous continuons à boire la même eau
de Sainte-Lucie Que se passe-t-il pour que le
apports d'eau douce
à la rivière Santa Lucía sont moindres ou rares
et la plus grande contribution est l'eau salée de la rivière
de l'argent
[Musique]
nous n'avons pas eu beaucoup de questions et ceci
nous avons utilisé de l'eau minérale ou des voix
nous avons décidé de mettre une pancarte il y a un mois
plus ou moins ceci, rien à dire
nous avons utilisé cette eau en bouteille pour le
fabrication de tous nos produits
[Musique]